i dream about being with you forever
forever
hey twyhards think you know everything
there is to know about the twilight saga
well this video might just change that
the twilight cast are all
amazing actors but they have a hidden
talent
improv did you know that bella and
edward's treetop scene was
actually unscripted robert just kept
ad-libbing
that's why in this video we'll be going
over all the surprising twilight saga
moments where the actors weren't really
acting
dang an older woman ah
when bella meets the cullens for the
first time the only thing better than
rosalie's sass
the entire family will be implicated if
this ends badly
i would become the male is when edward
takes bella up to the treetops of the
forest
it's the first time bella and the
audience get to see him in action
well kristen stewart revealed that
robert pattinson actually ad-libbed one
of the most popular lines of the
scene bella is basically questioning
everything that's going on in this scene
who wouldn't and when she says this kind
of stuff just doesn't exist
it doesn't my world edward's response
was all rob
according to kristin that wasn't the
only part of the treetop scene that rob
pulled out of his back pocket
now this next line is actually pretty
controversial in the way that people
literally get secondhand embarrassment
when they hear it
are you ready you better hold on tight
spider monkey
director catherine hardwick had been
trying to find a line that would work
for the moment
and that's what rob came up with
honestly it makes us think whether or
not the ad-lib was meant to be a joke
considering how honest rob's been with
how ridiculous he thinks the twilight
scripts are
so if you've been wondering exactly what
a spider monkey is for the last decade
try asking rpatz after watching four
movies
we all know how attracted vampires are
to bella's scent
you do smell good anyone else still kind
of creeped out about that
so in eclipse when jacob helps carry her
through the forest to create a false
trail
it makes total sense but filming the
scene was actually pretty difficult
taylor lautner may have a toned body but
he isn't as strong as a werewolf
they had a lever that was meant to hold
kristen so that taylor could deliver
basically a four minute monologue
but it didn't work out taylor improvised
toughened it out and just carried
kristen himself the crew was probably
extremely grateful for his improvisation
drowning is scary no doubt about it
but apparently so is pretending to drown
after bella's cliff-diving escapade
she almost meets her demise when filming
that scene
kristen actually had to get in a body of
water with weights in her pockets to
make it seem more real
the fear on her face in the scene wasn't
scripted it's all kristin
the director chris wheats finally
decided to remove the weights after
trying it out himself
it's day 20 and things are just getting
stranger kristen's favorite scene in the
entire film
was completely improvised but it got
deleted
according to the actress it was just a
casual moment between kristen and edward
where they were only told to have a
conversation they thought their
characters would be having
i don't think i could take care of
myself i know you can't
the filmmakers thought the scene wasn't
worth the final cut but kristin totally
disagrees
it's a wolf thing what's a wolf thing
taylor lautner didn't really get the
whole concept of imprinting
same taylor same so when he was given a
script with no instruction on how to
make it look like he was imprinting on a
literal newborn
he knew he had to improvise the entire
moment
so not only was the whole moment thought
up by taylor
renesme was completely done later on in
the editing room
that means to top it all off he
imprinted on an invisible baby
it's like gravity your whole center
shifts
that's a tough one we're not going to
lie luckily stephanie meyer was on set
for moral support and to re-explain what
imprinting was
it's time the cullens baseball scene
might just be the most iconic scene in
not even just the twilight film but the
twilight book
vampires playing baseball during a
thunderstorm does it even get
better than that come on it's just a
game
well what we're about to tell you might
just be the cherry on top of a perfect
scene
jackson rathbone improvised all of his
skills with his bat
actually he didn't even know he was
being filmed he was just fooling around
between takes and the cameras just
happened to be rolling
it is not cgi and i can still do it to
this day with some editing
the b-roll became the a-roll jackson do
you have real-life vampire skills you've
been hiding
speaking of jackson he had another scene
where he added his own tidbit to the
script
remember when he went all newborn and
tried to attack bella at her birthday
party in new moon
well the scene was actually more intense
than it was meant to be
thanks to jackson he got so in character
that he actually got other actors peter
fatinelli and kellen lutz
to hold him back because he was starting
to terrify kristin
that's some major method acting jackson
it's okay it's just a little blood
moving on to another major fight in
twilight we have the final showdown
between edward and james in the ballet
studio
you're faster than the others but not
stronger
i'm strong enough to kill you vampire
fights are intense
which means to prep they bring in stunt
doubles and get the actors to learn
fight choreography so no one gets hurt
but robert and cam jagande decided to
veer off the choreography and
improvise their own fight instead their
unscripted moves may have just been for
fun
but they ended up making the final cut
it must have looked more natural
jessica may get jealous of bella and
edward sometimes but she was still there
to cheer bella up during new moon and
have a girls night out
but anna kendrick took the scene a whole
step further
now that she's gone on to do other
franchises like pitch perfect
we know how amazing she is however check
out what she did before she was starring
in all these blockbusters
i want to sit through all those zombies
eating people and no hot guys kissing
anybody
her entire monologue about the trash
zombie movie in this scene
was improvised the entire thing
kudos to her that must not have been an
easy thing to keep on reshooting
perfectly
beauty is pain right at least for
vampires in the twilight saga
it is the transition process is painful
but at least the actors had some fun
filming the scenes
when robert filmed edward's transition
scene with peter faccinelli
it was all silent that means when peter
went to lean into rob's ear
he could literally say anything so every
time they shot the scene
he would improvise something different
first thing i said i'm sorry
it started off normal but by the end he
was whispering stuff like you're
attractive
they struggled to keep a straight face
the entire time
okay so maybe filming the scene was
painful in another way
i've held her once and already you think
that you have wolfie claim on
her so to be fair on-screen babies don't
really act they're just
there but the baby who was playing
renesmee during her birth scene
was having a little too much fun instead
of fake blood the costume department had
to use a mix of jelly and cream cheese
so they wouldn't irritate her skin
well the baby thought it was delicious
you can actually see them trying to lick
the spreads throughout the entire birth
scene
honestly this might be the most adorable
improv moment
without this video we probably would
have had no idea how many scenes were
actually improvised
hold on tight spider monkey that line is
basically iconic and it was
all our paths no wonder the entire cast
are such huge actors
even more than a decade later what was
your favorite improvised scene
do you know of any other unscripted
moments let us know in the comment
section below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and thanks for watching
[Music]